[Music]
good morning John it's Friday April 29th
there people walking around upstairs
people I don't know people interested in
buying my house today has not been a
good day today's not been a good day
I've been a bad day and I don't know
what to do about it except maybe leave
town which is what Katherine and I are
doing shortly yeah there's people
looking at the house to see if they want
to buy it and kick us out my first one
my cheese dogs this is my girl here the
foundation right there right
first hurts I also had a conference call
this morning with on the websites that I
worked for it didn't go exactly as well
as I would have liked it to um I would
have liked them to have offered me lots
of money and they didn't but that's not
really why I'm so upset
I've done web pages for a living it's
what I do I make money and it allows me
to pay bills it allows me to do
Brotherhood 2.0 it allows me to make
video blogs because I don't have to
leave the house every day to go to work
it allows me to be here with you what am
i kind doesn't paying me it's been a
really long time and they haven't paid
me I just got an email from them and
they said that they're having trouble
coming up with the money trouble coming
put the money my money I gave them
months of my life or they're having a
hard time coming up with the money what
mob money I don't know how this happened
but I need that money and if you know
anybody who is a professional you know a
professional it would be nice if you
could email me their contact information
especially because then I would get to
punish you but there's good news
there's good news the good news is that
Katherine and I are leaving town we're
going to Helena to see Neil Gaiman's who
I'm sure many of the nerdfighters know
and I will do my best to get a little
bit of Neil Gaiman saying hello to John
okay
tee's now now we're also going to visit
some friends and it's very exciting
other good news I heard that the Yeti
got a job started Catherine and
Catherine doesn't have to move to
Indianapolis Indiana to get it you know
there's generally a reason why houses
are almost free in a place and that
reason is generally because a place
isn't the best place houses are
expensive in Missoula because it's the
best place so now you know not to panic
a day looking forward to the weekend
congratulations to Catherine she's going
to be doing weed research yeah this
one's good mark that one bound good in
your notebook other good news Tobias is
amazing and made an album of our songs
I'm thinking of a new one for next week
again help it
songs are fun but since we're about to
leave town I have to do a bunch of stuff
I have to get eco geek all ready to go I
have to pack Catherine is making sure
there's someone to take care of the cat
and the garden and they need to write I
need to write a lot because I don't lose
my job cuz it's the only one I have now
so I have to go John I will see you on
Monday and by then we will all know what
happened at the LA Times Book Award we
don't have any expectations we're just
curious you can click on the link down
there and at 8 o'clock Pacific Daylight
Time the winners will be announced and
we will all be holding our breath until
then hopefully John will have footage of
the event on Monday even though it is
illegal to bring a video camera into the
event I have confidence in his smuggling
skills ok now I really have to go John
I'll see you on Monday